le métro a 50 ans et oui monsieur
chappuis cinquante ans déjà vous avez
été le premier le 19 juillet 1900 à
mettre en marche la première rame du
métro porte maillot vincennes vous
souvenez vous monsieur chatouille 1900
on criait alors au miracle et monsieur
une chance bienvenue père du
métropolitain apparaissait comme la plus
grande figure de l'année monsieur
pulgent ce bienvenue a disparu mais dans
le fond ça n'a pas tellement changé
n'est ce pas monsieur chat puis le métro
passe toujours au dessus de passif
il ya toujours au guichet de pénible
recherche de monnaie et d'âpres
discussions au portillon et les visages
sont aussi toujours un peu semblable les
visages du métro celui de l'ouvrier
encore un peu endormi au matin ceux des
amoureux les plus immuable peut-être et
les attitudes sans gêne du monsieur qui
veut à tout prix tenir son journal il ya
toujours de temps en temps quelques
clubs descendant prolongeant son voyage
bien au delà des tunnels et qui se
révèle juste à temps pour oublier
quelque chose
aussi depuis cinquante ans un endroit à
changer un endroit s'est agrandi le
bureau des objets trouvés justement
et puis il y aussi quelque chose de
disparus la guille courtoisie de la
belle époque qui a fait place à une
forme plus particulière de l'aviation
mais à part cela monsieur chat puis
franchement vous qui l'avez l'unef il ya
50 ans avouez qu'il supporte allègrement
le poids des ans
ce vieil ami des parisiens qui toutes
les trois minutes régulièrement dans les
deux sens salue au passage la tour
eiffel